comme à part nos 28 ans dont 14 se
passer en cuisine depuis mai dernier le
jeune chef dirige des fourneaux du grand
monarque à chartres peu de monde en
cuisine ce 25 au matin le restaurant
étoilé est fermé en ce jour de noël et
c'est à la préparation d'un immense
potage de saison que s'emploie le chef
cuisinier on avait du navet de la
carotte d'oignons blancs oignons rouges
des poireaux on avait six un potimarron
voilà donc cédé des légumes des légumes
de saison des légumes d'hiver et au
départ je me suis dit je vais faire une
soupe mixer et petits qui au final au
final ce qu'on appelle un potage
cultivateurs cette soupe pour noël est
le fruit d'un large élan de solidarité
un grossiste de l'alimentaire a fourni
les 40 kilos de légumes quelques
cuisinier volontaires ont aidé à les
préparer un boulanger a apporté le pain
est une association de commerçants de
chartres a concrétisé la dimension
partage de cette soupe l'étoile est
offerte à l'heure du déjeuner aux plus
démunis et aux plus isolé
j'ai toujours aimé faire plaisir aux
gens ce métier de cuisine je le fais
pour ça aussi pour un plaisir au
quotidien et
monnet ans un chef qui j'ai secondes et
pendant deux ans mais des repas
notamment pour les enfants malades voilà
dire au repas ou les bénéfices étaient
le recteur au verset et puis la bella à
chartres n'étant pas de d'eure-et-loir
ni de chartres en ayant que le jour de
noël aujourd'hui pour propos j'ai décidé
de passer noël avec les chartrains les
chartraines les gens d'ailleurs qu'ils
souhaitent à venir passer un moment de
partage et de convivialité
cette initiative 2018 était une première
les protagonistes ayant visiblement pris
goût à cette soupe étoilé l'opération
pourrait bien se renouveler